[Music]
and this is why I don't want sat-nav in
my car overdue doctor who reviewed time
and this one as per usual is brought to
you by the radio verses of the Martians
podcast hosted by Mike Gillis and Casey
Doran discusses all manner of wonderful
pop-culture geekery TVs movies comics
wrestling even sometimes they'll talk
about Ghostbusters they'll talk about
Game of Thrones I'll talk about Star
Wars they'll talk about Batman they will
absolutely talk about Arnold
Schwarzenegger in every movie he's ever
made good and bad radio versus the
Martians great guests great topics give
it a listen at Radio versus the Martians
calm or wherever you get your podcasts
so two-parter time for season four which
gives us the Sontaran two-parter and
this one I've always enjoyed they I
actually liked it better this time that
I did previously which is nice when that
happens because these revisits like they
can honestly go any direction sometimes
sometimes I see something i and i liked
previously and i end up like finding
little things that I'm like oh or they
are things that I realized didn't age
great if it's a particularly old episode
sometimes I'll you know I'll watch
something that I really didn't like and
find maybe bits that are okay but for
the most part it's like mmm more often
than not it just kind of reaffirms
whatever opinion I already have but it's
nice to see something that I already
liked and go like this even a little
better so boy where do we begin
well the Sontarans being back that's
really cool that's just really nice I I
think the Sontarans are one of the
better updated creatures both in terms
of the design and certainly in terms of
this story
probably bring bring this up eventually
when when Strax gets introduced a bit
down the line but I kind of wish we
could get a serious Sontaran story again
because they are pretty effective
villains in this the guy who plays the
general generals general Staal something
like that ah I shouldn't double-check
that Staal the undefeated what if you do
get defeated were they gonna call you
then
solid the sometimes is defeated but
never mind
no not so defeated I got I know I should
be I should have looked this stuff up
man I'm lazy and it shows anyways
I like that they realized their
diminutive size i I'm not sure they
needed to tint the armor blue but the
armor looks pretty good
the design on the makeup is great
because it's incredibly true to the
original design
it's just refined with better techniques
and the performances are phenomenal from
the lead Sontaran so that's the general
and that is a score who is played by the
same actor who would later play Strax
here playing a Sontaran straight as
opposed to yo more for laughs but I like
their military approach to things I like
the the way that the doctor is able to
wind them up by accusing them of
cowardice by just not taking them
seriously and it's one of the things
that I I wish would happen more often
when the doctor encounters villains that
he's run into before more often than not
it just ends up being a doctor we reach
again or for the doctors like oh it's
this we're in trouble kind of thing but
I like the doctor just knowing how to
wind somebody up and it's done really
well here and maybe part of that is
because the Sontarans lend themselves to
that a bit more I mean you can't really
it's hard to wind up a Dalek or a
Cyberman you can stall them a little but
you can't quite get under their skin in
the same way that you can't with say a
Sontaran
Sontarans have pride man do they have
pride but you know was the big thing
that actually worked
way better for me in this and before
book i kind of considered a flaw of the
story Ratigan he worked surprisingly
well for me here and I think the thing
was is I keyed in much more this viewing
on his youth and that is what makes the
character work because had he been a
more mature or adult character being
manipulated by the Sontarans he would
just be I he'd be like a Captain Planet
villain basically but to feed into the
arrogance of intelligent youth and this
whole thing where like he gets excited
at having helped kill people because to
him it's still all largely hypothetical
it's all largely theoretical because
he's smart enough to imagine and
understand these things but he lacks the
life experience to ground so much of
what he's doing or getting himself
involved in and sort of that fact gets
thrown in his face very harshly which
kind of turns him around and gives him
his Redemption moment at the end I also
like I like the whole thing with the
doctor you know he knows how to defeat
the Sontarans but he has to go himself
to activated because as he tells donna
and Martha I have to give them the
choice and it made me flashback to
boomtown and Eccleston's doctor talking
to that one remaining Slovene and how
you know this is how you live with
yourself every now and then you let them
you let one go
and I flashback to that because this is
how the doctor lives with himself he he
gives them the choice to stop explicitly
and if they don't then he'll do what he
has to do but he can't just leap to that
then he couldn't live with himself end
result is still the same more often than
not but that
how he moves forward I like that
I mentioned Martha so let's Martha's
back and that's kind of cool um I feel
like they could have done with more time
with her away and I don't say that being
like I regret having her back no she's
good she's solid in this and it's just
that it she wasn't gone long enough for
me to miss her yet I mean that this is
only so let me think here so it would
have been the Christmas special partners
in crime
so she's only been gone for four stories
yeah yeah no I think I think a little
more time would it would have benefited
and made the return feel better I
actually kind of like the guy who's in
charge of unit um he you know the guys
doing his best obviously but he's also
completely out of his league but not in
a way that feels um disrespectful or
mocking of of who he is and you know his
military background I mean the doctor
has a kind of a low opinion of him
related to that but yeah I don't feel
like this show is particularly mocking
of him and even he's even a write a few
times or has some good ideas or some
good points every now and then so that's
kind of nice
donna is great o clocks this on turn
back in the neck and oh we get will we
get more time with like Donna's family
I normally I complain about the domestic
stuff with the families but first of all
of them we get Donna back home we get
Wilf and oh oh yes I I will always want
more well he's so good he's so good with
Donna he's good with the doctor um and
actually even Donna's mother who's a
little bit a little bit irritating she's
a little bit reminiscent of Jackie in
some ways but I don't know she I did I
think it's just cuz she's counterbalance
by Wilf that it that she didn't even bug
me all that much but I love
then back even for like little bits and
a few scenes and to help ground the
danger of what's happening to London and
the world you keep coming back to them
slowly choking and it makes it much more
real so that works really well oh you
know who else I liked Ross the unit
guide that the doctor gets paired off
with for a little bit actually was kind
of annoyed that they killed him I wish
they would have kept him around I would
have liked to have him like just be
there like next time unit showed up
again I think that would have been
really really nifty but for the time
that we get him and that the doctor kind
of comes to appreciate him after
initially dismissing him as a grunt and
then having affection for him and then
pointing out to the commander you know
that's a man you whose life you just you
just allowed to die you lose his life
for nothing
I think Raza Ross was was a good was he
was good stuff for as long as he lasted
and this is just a really solid episode
I mean it's not top tier it doesn't have
like that extra twist or emotional hook
in that like the very best of doctor who
has but for it sits in the upper range
of stuff that is missing that because
something can be missing those sort of
like little extra oh that's the best
kind you know stuff that really puts it
over the top and still be quite good and
I feel like this two-parter is in the
upper tier of that kind of story it
lacks the the little extra something to
make it an all-time classic but what it
does it does really well and I really
enjoy it yeah I have fun with this one
oh and Donna
super temp I like I love that they find
ways that her very mundane experiences
let her figure stuff out I loved on us
so much uh in any case first two-parter
of series four you seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it hit the like button
while you're there that's driving the
algorithm these days so far as I can
tell
Plus subscribing
wouldn't mind that patreon supporter of
them but there's merch there's social
media links this up in the description
on the stuff click on it or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]